protesters in panama burned tires and
blocked roads once again in the capital
and across the country in a meeting on
monday morning a majority of protesters
literally tore up the agreement reached
with the government late on sunday to
end the blockades in exchange for
further reducing the price of petrol
we had told the government we had to
consult with the rank and file the
agreement was signed under pressure the
people have decided and i comply with
their decision we want to tell the
education minister who could not be here
today that there is no agreement unless
the issues behind this crisis are
resolved
[Applause]
protesters now want more than the
government's plan to reduce the price of
fuel medicine and food unions and
indigenous groups are now demanding a
national negotiation to address
political corruption and discuss larger
political reforms
we have said repeatedly that there has
to be one negotiating table we have said
that its structural issues need to be
addressed
no more common go on a few cents
reduction on gasoline prices
some with the cost of food since
businessmen keep accumulating wealth
the government so far has not responded
the blockades on the pan-american
highway that connects panama with the
rest of central america and is the
country's main route for basic goods
entered a third week
economists warned the demonstrations
have cost the country millions of
dollars in losses and are leading to
shortages of fuel and food
on monday most stalls at panama's main
produce market closed early for lack of
fruits and vegetables
everything is stuck few things arrive
a little tomato onions peppers or
carrots and potatoes
and usually we can only sell 30 or so of
what arrives the rest is already room
for being blocked for days
panama faces increasing social unrest
and getting further away from finding a
solution to end it alessandra
al jazeera